in this video we'll talk about the
differences between euchromatin and
heterochromatin
so the building block of Chromatin is
nucleosome which comprises of DNA and
histones
now if we look into a nucleus we would
find several chromatin domain which are
densely packed
and there are certain domains which are
Loosely packed the densely packed
regions are known as heterochromatin
whereas euchromatin is the region which
are Loosely packed and more accessible
heterochromatin and euchromatin are
widely different we would try to
understand how they are different at a
molecular level
so obviously from a structural point of
view heterochromatin is densely packed
and euchromatin is Loosely packed
heterochromatin is associated with
silence genes whereas euchromatin is a
hub for active transcription
so let's try to understand what are the
molecular factors that differentiates
these two structural domains in a
chromatin
first of all we need to understand the
status of different histone modification
along the chromatin region second of all
we need to understand about different
histone variants and thirdly we need to
understand about DNA methylation status
all of these factors would dictate how
accessible a chromatin is and how much
that can influence a transcription or
any other kind of gene expression
process
so first thing is histone modification
so when it comes to euchromatin there
are several histone modifications such
as acetylation and specially acetylation
in H3 or H4 residues are associated with
a euchromatin or open chromatin state
acetylations like h3k9 acetylation h2k14
acetylation h4k acetylations are very
prominent among others
methylation like h3k 36 methylation h3k4
dimethylation is very common in
eugromatin phosphorylation like h3s10p
is very common in euchromatin region
heterochromatin regions are often
associated with several methylations
such as h3k27
dimethylation or mono methylation
h420 mono methylation Etc
so what we can appreciate at this point
that the histone marks at the
euchromatin region and heterochromatin
regions are broadly different
and all these marks would dictate how
the chromatin is tightly wrapped around
in a particular region because if there
is acetylation you can understand the
chromatin would be Loosely packed and it
would be accessible towards many factors
if you want to learn more about these
histone modification processes you can
click on the I button
now there are several histone variants
which can delineate between euchromatin
and heterochromatin regions in
euchromatin region one can find h2az or
H 3.3 histone variants whereas in
heterochromatin region one can find H
3.1 3.2 sent a macro h2a these kind of
variants
H1 histone is another important player
which can discriminate between new
chromatin and heterochromatin often it
was noticed that H1 histone deposition
was fairly low in the euchromatin region
so H1 histone's job is to make the
chromatin further compact so if we have
less H1 histone deposition the chromatin
is expected to be more accessible and
Loosely wrapped whereas in
heterochromatin region there is a high
density of H1 histone which can be
associated with several complexes that
recruit factors for
heterochromatinization
now let's look at the methylation Mark
and how they are different between
euchromatin and heterochromatin so in
the heterochromatin region one can see
hypermethylation so there are so many
methyl marks in the heterochromatin
region compared to euchromatin region
which is generally hypometed now all
these factors are really important for
gene expression because in order for
gene expression to happen transcription
factors need to gain access to a
promoted region and thereby starting the
transcription and this accessibility
issue can be solved only when you don't
have too much of nucleosome density so
chromatin accessibility is a very
important factor that dictates the
transcription
that is why euchromatin is generally
transcriptionally active whereas
heterochromatin is transcriptionally
silent
now how to understand a particular
reason is euchromatin or heterochromatin
like so is there a high throughput a
technology to do that yes exactly by
performing attack sequencing we can
understand for a particular cell type at
a particular time which regions of the
genome are heterochromatinized versus
euchromatinized
so if the genome is more accessible
so we would be seeing attack Peaks now
if you want a more detailed video on a
taxi you can click on the I button but
if the region is heterochromatinized and
the nucleosome density is very high
attack Peaks would not be seen that
means attack Peak would tell us about
the accessibility of the chromatin at
that particular region so in this video
we looked at the differences between
euchromatin and heterochromatin from
different points of view like histone
variance histone modification Linker
histone DNA methylation status and the
overall accessibility of Chromatin
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up you
can find more notes and flashcards in
Facebook Channel you can uh support the
channel by clicking on the super thanks
option underneath the video you can pay
via paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video